[Música]
segundo bloque de economía esta mañana
de lunes en directo América de France 24
y Daniel hablandon está con nosotros en
el estudio Dani que bueno tenerla
nuevamente y el kremlin ya respondió a
esta entrada en vigor el día de hoy de
las sanciones más duras por parte de
occidente a su ingreso por el petróleo
Raúl pues recordemos primero rápidamente
estas medidas Y es que la Unión Europea
los países del g7 que son Alemania
Canadá Estados Unidos Francia Italia
Japón y Reino Unido y a todos ellos se
le suma ahora Australia se Proponen
ahogar las finanzas del kremlin cómo lo
van a hacer con dos medidas que aplican
desde este lunes primero un boicot a las
exportaciones de petróleo por mar Aunque
sí seguirá llegando por oleoducto para
blindar a países como Hungría que no
tienen salida al mar y que dependen en
gran medida de los hidrocarburos rusos
la segunda y que más ha molestado al
kremlin es la de un tope de 60 dólares
por barril al precio de su petróleo el
gobierno ruso dijo hoy que suspenderá
las entregas a los países que le
apliquen este tope y que de todas
maneras esto no afectará la ofensiva en
Ucrania
en este momento se está preparando una
decisión pero lo que está claro es que
no aceptaremos ningún tope de precios la
situación en los mercados petroleros
cambiará
lo que es obvio e indiscutible es que
tomar estas decisiones es un paso hacia
la desestabilización de los mercados
energéticos mundiales
Dani le pregunto cómo va a funcionar
todo esto Raúl en plata Blanca quiere
decir que occidente ya no va a comprar
tanto petróleo al segundo mayor
productor mundial Así que el impacto del
tope se va a ver en las compañías de
seguros y otras empresas de la cadena de
suministro que solamente podrán tratar
con El crudo ruso si este tiene un
precio igual o inferior a ese tope que
hay que decirlo va a ser revisado cada
dos meses la mayoría de esas firmas
están ubicadas en la Unión Europea o en
Reino Unido pero esta sanción pasaría
Casi inadvertida ya que hoy en día Rusia
vende su petróleo a poco más de esos 65
dólares 70 75 Dólares inclusive llegó el
día de hoy
se ha desviado hacia países asiáticos o
del medio oriente para que le compren lo
que le sobra por eso muchos países
estaban presionando para que ese tope
fuera más bajo por ejemplo de 50 dólares
por qué Raúl porque se estima que Rusia
le cuesta entre 30 y 40 y 40 dólares
producir un barril y su equilibrio
fiscal se logra si lo vende a un precio
de entre 60 y 70 dólares todavía Dentro
de este Rango es decir que sigue siendo
relativamente rentable venderlo O al
menos para no perder esa producción que
ya tiene es así Dani Y ante todo esto
que está ocurriendo hablemos de los
indicadores Cómo amanecieron los precios
los precios hoy del petróleo pues estas
medidas aplicadas contra Rusia podrían
tener a corto plazo un efecto muy
incierto en el mercado petrolero primero
hay preocupaciones sobre la pérdida de
suministro desde Rusia y eso Sube los
precios ante una expectativa de mayor
demanda y menor oferta pero al mismo
tiempo hay temores sobre precisamente
una menor demanda en la economía global
que está en desaceleración y eso
contribuye a bajarlos así que no se sabe
cuál es el efecto que va a ser en el
mediano plazo y en el corto plazo de lo
que sí podemos hablar es de la jornada
de hoy en la que los contratos a futuro
sobre el barril han llegado a
valorizarse hasta en 2% por encima de
los 80 dólares para el caso de la
referencia wti del Golfo de México y 87
dólares en el brent del mal del mar del
Norte pero la Unión Europea tiene otras
preocupaciones una de ellas es Estados
Unidos por qué pues hoy se están
reuniendo los representantes comerciales
del bloque comunitario y de Estados
Unidos para hablar sobre esta polémica
ley de reducción de inflación de Joe
biden Europa teme que los créditos
Fiscales para comprar vehículos
eléctricos les quite competitividad a
sus fabricantes de vehículos la comisión
europea está analizando Si en lugar de
incrementar la atención con la Casa
Blanca debería mejor revisar sus propias
normas y porque no también promover un
proyecto parecido a este de reducción de
inflación
la ley de reducción de inflación debería
hacernos reflexionar sobre Cómo podemos
mejorar nuestro marco de ayuda Estatal y
adaptarlo a un nuevo entorno global si
nos fijamos en esa ley hace inversiones
a lo largo de la cadena de valor en
algunos sectores estratégicos y este no
siempre es el caso con nuestra ayuda
Estatal
bueno Daniela un lunes muy movido en
cuanto a estas sanciones a Rusia y todo
lo que tiene que ver con el mercado
petrolero vamos a ver qué nos espera
mañana en términos económicos esto
promete ser un tema que nos dará para
hablar todo diciembre así y el resumen y
vamos también a hablar de ese tema con
más profundidad el día jueves